he met his life partner from a chat a
chance encounter at a frat house
everyone please welcome Benji
um I'm gonna bring you back to fall
2021. you can imagine where you were
um I was sitting in my dining room table
and I had just gone off a scheduled Zoom
call
at midnight
and I'm sitting there and before I
poured myself a second glass of bourbon
I thought I thought to myself what what
got me here why why was I here getting
off of a scheduled Zoom call at midnight
and
um well at the time we were
um my company I was one of five
employees there and we were trying to
drive hard build our product get it out
into customers respond to what they need
and through this process of trying to
deliver as quickly as possible
my colleague and I who are the only
technical people on staff at the time
found ourselves up until midnight trying
to deliver and I thought was trying to
think of a way of how I could
communicate this problem to my
non-technical co-workers who always
thought well the client asked for it
let's get it to them as soon as possible
so we can really show value
um but over time obviously this created
a lot of problems
um and even though I came up in this
world as a data scientist and a
Consulting type environment where I
would do analysis we would do analysis
on a regular basis and then deliver it
and then move on to the next thing at
this point we were delivering things
more in a like a product company
um and I wasn't really familiar with
this framework but I found that this was
the framework to talk about the problems
we were having with my non-technical
co-workers
um I've given this talk before so and
More in like a business context and less
of a government policy context so I've
tried to adapt it to that but really the
lessons are the same regardless of where
you're at
um so I'm Benji Braun I'm the Chief
Architect at a company called
202 group slash blue voyant Government
Solutions we're going through a bit of a
awkward Rebrand right now
um but
um I I do I've done a lot of things over
the past three years but when it was
just the five of us and just two
technical people I really kind of did
everything
um and so I have had this experience of
building a product and understanding
um the problems you have when you build
with tech debt which as I'll explain is
inevitable but
um I hope that you will learn something
from my mistakes so you won't have to
make them yourself
um so the goals for this talk I'd like
to Define what tech debt is I've talked
to some of you guys about this talk
already and some of you are familiar
with this concept some of you aren't so
I'd like to Define it
um then I'd like to
talk about a new way of thinking about
this that you can talk about with your
non-technical colleagues that will help
um help you help help you outline this
problem and then um since I went to
business school there's going to be a
framework got to have a framework and
then we'll you know we'll wrap it up
um okay so so definitions what is Tech
debt here's like a pretty
um jargony example so in software
intensive systems technical debt is a
collection of design or implementation
constructs that are expedient in the
short term but set up a technical
context that can make future changes
more costly or impossible so what you do
something now
later you have to pay for it you have to
pay that debt back right okay Ward
Cunningham who actually coined the term
this is what he says a little debt
speeds development so long as it is paid
back promptly with a rewrite the danger
occurs when the debt is not repaid and
so this is what was happening why we
were up till midnight or later really
fixing these problems is because in the
speed to want to deliver this piece of
data or this feature to a client we were
writing bad code we're doing things that
were inefficient and layering on top of
that so all our problems stacked one on
top of the other
um we weren't repaying our debt
um you know or a sales product
perspective why can't Engineers just
shut up and Implement those features
already I'm trying to close the sale I
think like a lot of this is the
perspective that technical people don't
non-technical people don't really get
um I think we've heard this in one of
the other talks earlier today or
yesterday that a lot of people think
what we do is Magic
um and they don't understand what takes
what what takes a long time what doesn't
take a long time why you should do
things fast so let's talk about a way
from that someone can care someone who's
not technical can care so it's not just
about complaining that they can get um
they can start to care about it
okay so I put this in here because I
definitely didn't think of myself this
way but I've started to think about it
um especially as a in building a product
and I never thought of myself as a
software engineer but I've I've started
to and I think that's a good a good
thing so you can be a software engineer
even if you don't write JavaScript or
PHP or Java you're still writing
software your the code you write those
scripts are pieces of software
um and you should try to build them in
such a way so that you're not
um acquiring writing it you're not
writing it poorly you're doing a but in
addition to not writing it poorly you're
writing in the most optimal way possible
so that it's not rebuilding the wheel
every time you do it
okay so we we think and I think we've
set up this
um this this dichotomy between like the
tech side of the house and I before I
said business but let's call it policy
and like the government context between
like the technical people on the
analysts let's say and they're like
they're against each other that the
analysts don't understand why the tech
people can't just get it done and the
tech people don't understand why the
analysts keep asking them to take
shortcuts and making it work worse and
this is a really big problem because
your mission or like the business isn't
those two competing forces it's those
two forces working together so you need
to be on the same page to to to to to
work on it and to to figure this out and
this was a big problem the first time I
tried to talk to my team about tech that
the non-technical people I thought it
was going to be like a really easy
framework and people got really
defensive with it
um and I think that was my fault because
I didn't propose it from a business
standpoint of what they could do to do
why this was better for the business not
just like why it was going to make
better code because like at the end of
the day why do they care if the code's
good or not if the business outcomes are
the same
okay so Tech Deck can be both a good
thing or a bad thing so Tech Deck could
be a problem
um in the way that this is like a graph
I've seen in a few different places but
this often happens with software
organizations in general which is that
as time goes on productivity goes down
but cost goes up so like the idea is
that you know it takes longer to
implement those features it takes longer
to do the analysis to build that model
what do you do you hire more people okay
so those takes those people longer and
longer to do it
and instead of fixing the problem you're
just layering on top of that problem
every time you hire new people it makes
the problem worse
okay but Tech Deck can also be an asset
so you can get your product into users
hands more quickly you can explore
product fit without making big
Investments
um and you can test new capabilities and
respond
um respond quickly like think of like
the agile the agile framework like you
do something in a in a Sprint you see
how the customer interacts with it you
can go back and make changes okay so
let's think of it in a way that manages
these concerns
um
so there's this concept of behavior
value and structure value from you know
famous or inFAMOUS depending on how you
think about it Robert C Martin he's you
know he's definitely an [ __ ] but like
I think he's right about this and so
what he's saying is that software has
two types of value one is behavior value
and one is structure value so Behavior
value is the value that the stakeholder
customer makes or saves from the product
so this is like what you get out of the
like what you actually get out of the
product
right so like um
the app like you people talked about a
lot today about shiny apps so like what
the value the customer gets by being
able to use a shiny app to download that
data versus you know emailing you for it
so that's Behavior value so structured
value on the other hand is the ease and
promptness of creating and changing
features in an existing system so if
um if we're providing someone a shiny
app and I'm like well you know what I
really need a I I want to be able to
download it as an Excel CSV or text
how hard it is to add that button is the
structure value of of it and the value
of the whole system is those together
it's both the ability to change and what
it does right now
so this is the frame so that when we
came to it like that before I get into
like the framework of taking on taking
out good Tech debt versus bad Tech debt
is um is that it's that Value Plus
structure and this was the way that I
was able to communicate to my
non-technical uh like co-workers the
importance of taking this into account
so it's like hey so and so asks for this
this button or this data set this
analysis I want to get it to them you
know today tomorrow it's like okay well
I have you know all these other things
going on I can do that
but it's going to make it harder to to
answer the next request so let's think
about is it worth it to do that it could
be you know you know who's asking for it
what does it contribute to like the
long-term vision of this product of this
company or is it just like I need I need
to make the client happy I gotta do it
um which isn't really like a good way to
you know like that type of development
isn't like a good way to develop
okay so framework
um you know the debt metaphor I think is
a really good one in finance they talk
of talk about like present value versus
future value and
um I'm not sure how many of you are
familiar with this concept but that's in
in finance this is like I take out a
loan today for let's say a hundred
dollars in 10 years is I'm gonna get a
hundred and ten dollars back so that's
the present value versus the future
value so
this is like the the thing with
responding to a customer's need or want
like does the present value I get from
delivering this equal more value later
on or do I get am I going to have to do
more work than it's worth later on I
think someone earlier today was talking
about like is the juice worth the
squeeze
um
so good way to think about in the same
the same context
um so smaller or variable loan versus
large fixed loan so
um
this is you know to carry on that
Finance example so is there a way to
make yourself more flexible than
um than really commit right now
um sometimes it's better to make a
decision that is sub-optimal but it
leaves your options open
um this could be like look for you know
for us it was our Cloud environment we
originally went to
um AWS commercial and we had to move
over to govcloud because of client
requirements but in the beginning that
gave us a lot more options
um there's a lot more services in
commercial it's less it's less expensive
um versus going over to govcloud even
though in the long run that's what we
needed to do at the time we need to keep
our options open so it was better to do
that
all right this is probably the most I
don't know if this is the most important
but I think this is a lot where you get
to make a lot of different decisions
about you what you want to avoid and
what you try to not want to avoid
um I think people incorrectly sometimes
think about tech debt is write bad code
now fix it later
um I don't maybe that's the type of tech
debt but I think that's just bad like
you should just write try to write the
best code you can
um especially because you will have to
fix it later like you're not gonna you
will have to change that code later and
it's so much harder to change poorly
written code than well written code like
I mean it's a joke you know it's it's a
it's an overused expression
um but it's true like you need to write
your code so that you remember it next
week I mean you really for me like
tomorrow so if I wrote bad code it's
going to be hard for me to tell what it
is all the more so when you're working
with a team when you're building a
product and not just doing analysis so
that's just like bad code okay that's
the type of tech that try to write don't
don't write bad code okay but
um sometimes you take
um you take out Tech debt deliberately
so for example
um our company right now has a uh like a
professional front end with JavaScript
developers that's like pretty cool
um but originally we couldn't afford
um you know like an engineering staff
like a front-end engineering step so we
built um our markdown websites and
deployed them using our studio connect
and it was like a good enough solution
we knew that someday that wasn't going
to work anymore that we were going to
have to rebuild everything from scratch
because we were going to outgrow that
system but it was good for then and that
that was acknowledged versus like
Reckless and accidental Tech debt
um for us
um the biggest example for us was our
approach to cyber security and cyber
security compliance we just didn't think
about it and I've spent the past year
just basically working on cyber security
compliance let not even really touching
actual cyber security
um and now we've finally now now that we
finally understand the ramifications of
that we've hired someone to really like
fix those problems that we've created
over this year much harder to do that
for a system that's already built than
baking it in from the beginning
all right design for flexibility I think
this this kind of covered this in a few
ways
um but you really have to leave yourself
open
um because you don't know how things are
going to change and I think a good
metaphor for this is that software data
science it's not like building a house
or a car like you you often when you
start your project or start working with
a client you don't really know where
you're going you have an idea and you're
building towards that but that's going
to change as you go on whereas like a
house you know I hire a general
contractor to fix my kitchen when he's
done with a punch list it's over for a
software project or a data science
project when you're working with someone
they're going to be changes to that
system through its lifetime and that's
expected so you have to build in
flexibility where you can
all right and then the last
was I a slide that's what I think I must
have had a double there and so the last
thing is to invest in professional
development
um we talked about good code bad code
decisions but so many of these
inadvertent Tech debt that people take
out is because they just don't know you
don't know what you don't know and if
you as you learn more and you invest in
your people to learn more they will
at least know what type of decisions
they're making
um and I think like that's why you know
we have things like this getting
together here like I've learned so many
things that I didn't know about talking
to you people to help us with that
all right so so recap
um so policy and Tech aren't separate
parts of the organization they are the
organization
you have to find a you have to think of
yourselves as partners and find a way to
move forward so that you're all
operating together
so Tech debt can be a mission problem or
asset depending on how it's management
how it's managed you can take out a bad
Tech debt that just
um is a that is just with you and like a
a something that you're attained to As
you move as you grow or it can be
something that helps you grow
and then
um you know these five points for take
for managing Tech debt try to understand
whether the present value is greater
than the future value whether the
smaller or variable loan is is better
that's better than taking a large fixed
loan
um making sure that you're doing things
deliberately versus accidentally if you
can building in flexibility and
investing in professional development
so lastly
um I'm actually I've talked to a few of
you about this I'm actually writing a
book about tech debt and about how it
applies to not just code but to all
aspects of a technical organization
um and if you have War stories about
times that you've decisions you made
that you wish you didn't or times that
you made what what made of in a
questionable decision or seemed like a
sub-optimal decision but that was the
right decision
um I'd love to talk to you I'd love for
you to reach out to me
um and thank you